hello and welcome to another
python mathematics and finance
indicators tutorial series
in this video the next couple videos
we're going to be talking about the
commodity
channel index or cci the commodity
channel index was developed by
donald lambert back in the 1980s the
idea of the cci
is to measure deviations from a
security's mean
or average price basically and it's
going to act as an
oscillator and oftentimes it's going to
be leading
but it's mostly there to indicate either
over bar oversold scenarios
like our rsi and some of the other ones
that we've discussed
also before we get into the calculation
cci despite its name commodity channel
index the cci is really used with
anything it doesn't have to be
commodities it can be
stocks forex etc so the calculation of
our
commodity channel index or cci is going
to be tp
and tp is going to equal typical price
and typical price is the high
plus the low plus the close divided by
three so kind of like an average
of those three numbers then it's going
to be minus
the a simple moving average of that
typical price
and the time frame for that simple
moving average uh is
at your discretion then uh that
top part of this fraction is going to be
divided by um
usually people use a .015
multiplied by the mean deviation
um but again you can kind of
uh play with this number as well as
obviously the time
frame number so let's go ahead and get
into
some examples before we start actually
programming this let me bring up
our example chart here so this is our
charting application if you want to know
how to make it check out our python
charting stocks tutorial series
otherwise um so here is
apple or not apple ebay
and i'm failing it fitting it here we go
so this bottom one here is our cci uh
generally
if it's above the 100 mark that would
consider it
uh overbought and if it's below the 100
mark
oversold but also you can just see that
many times it is indeed a leading
indicator as you can see here it starts
going down really before this one
actually started going down
uh then again same thing here it starts
swarming about
you know the decline pretty well in
advance there again
here and so on so anyways
not only can you use it for just
overbought and oversold you can almost
use it for trending
especially if you supplied a simple
moving average
of the cci line so that's kind of a
repeating thread across a lot of these
oscillators
is you can throw on a simple moving
average of this line and then you can
actually turn it into a single
signal line for trend changes
not just overbought and oversold
scenarios
so anyways uh definitely an interesting
oscillator um
so now let's go ahead and in the next
video what we're going to be doing is
actually programming this oscillator
into python
and the video after that we'll actually
chart it up just like this chart is so
anyway stay tuned for those videos as
always thanks for watching